what's everybody we're pond Finity and
today we want me needing these because
we're playing with other sports
equipment let's find out which one is
best potato tennis I've been preparing
for the big fight against the extremely
lightweight champion
[Music]
[Applause]
skiing is not my strong point but I'm
sure that I can play we're gonna be
playing a match to five points I'm gonna
be using the badminton racket and I'm
gonna be using bit tennis rackets but
first we're gonna need some practice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I think next we'll have to play
with a frisbee but since we only have
one frisbee that means me and Michal
have to share it
this should be fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
here's a challenge to all your football
players out there I'm going to see if
it's possible to play while bouncing the
ball
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now that we are warmed up it's time for
the big match he's gonna have no chance
we'll see that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we had a lot of fun filming this episode
last know in the comments below which
one was your favorite item if you
enjoyed this episode make sure to leave
a thumbs up subscribe right here and
watch our previous episodes here until
next time there's a cap it
[Music]